[Música]
surgió en 1985 antes de que nacieran
cuando después de un accidente mi madre
perdió al bebé que esperaba y meses
después se embarazo de mí esa fue mi
primera crisis nacer gracias a una
perdida para convertirme en lo que se
conoce como un bebé arco iris yo no
sabía entonces que era una crisis pero
estaba en el vientre de alguien que
tenía una
la segunda llegó cuando cumplí cuatro
años y comienza a ser abusada
sexualmente por dos primos y dos primas
tampoco sabía qué significaba una crisis
pero estaba teniendo una en carne propia
por primera vez
la tercera llegó cuando después de años
de feliz amnesia recordé los abusos y me
sentía humillada
ya sabía lo que significaba mi trabajo
era el manejo de crisis así que decidí
hacer arte con ella
mi nombre es alondra bear berg
y soy psicóloga en 2010 me gradué de la
especialidad en psicología clínica y me
convertí en una gran amante de los
laberintos de la mente humana era tan
entregada y tan demandante como alumna
que mi directora comenzó a llamarme
señorita perfección lo curioso es que
tuve que construir mi vida profesional
saliendo de una crisis para entrar en
otra mi trabajo era estar en el lugar
donde nadie quería estar interviniendo
en las situaciones de emergencia en
guerrero de ser una chica sobreprotegida
y criada en una burbuja rosa vas a
meterme en cárceles trabajar en el caso
y oficina para estar en albergues tras
desastres naturales viajar en carretera
con armas en los pies o estar con
pacientes en fases curativas paliativas
o terminales en un hospital
especializado en cáncer
aunque suene extraño estar la mayor
parte del tiempo en escenarios
desfavorables me llenaba de energía
el 2014 ya había terminado la maestría
en criminología a la parte ser
presidente de una asociación de salud
mental me había especializado en
intervención en crisis estaba estudiando
psicología el cognitiva conductual había
publicado mi primer libro ya había
atendido a 800 personas
con sólo 25 años sentía que mi vida era
exactamente como quería
hasta que una noche estando con mi novio
llegó a mi mente un recuerdo borroso en
el que alguien me besaba y tocaba siendo
una niña ese recuerdo había aparecido de
la nada por un olor poco habitual en la
habitación
pocos segundos después la imagen se
repetía y se repetía y se repetía en mi
cabeza
en ese momento me quedé paralizada en la
cama llorando y temblando sin poder
controlarme
mi novio me preguntó qué pasaba pero no
podía responder porque yo misma no lo
sabía
después de tratar de respirar y calmar
me el sugirió que quizá había sido
abusada sexualmente cuando era niña pero
yo no tenía un recuerdo de algo así
además quién diablos podría olvidar que
vivió abuso sexual infantil
así que pensé que podría ser una mala
jugada de mi imaginación o el recuerdo
de una pesadilla una película o
cualquier otra cosa
inicialmente no de importancia lo que
pasaba y quizá la situación se hubiese
detenido ahí
si no hubiese empezado a tener
pesadillas y pensamientos intrusos cada
vez más frecuentes e intensos
alguna vez les ha pasado que tiene una
pesadilla muy vivida muy real y pueden
recordar muchos detalles
excepto el rostro de las personas que
quieren hacerles daño
esa imagen confusa era la única pieza
que tenía para tratar de armar el
rompecabezas
cuando mi comportamiento empezó a
cambiar y mi dentadura se lastimó por la
violencia con que rechinaban los dientes
al dormir entendí que solo tenía dos
posibilidades descubría y enfrentaba lo
que me estaba causando conflicto
o dedicaba toda mi energía en tratar de
esquivar
para entender mi personalidad en
términos generales el primer paso fue la
revisión de mis evaluaciones
psicológicas si no tenía donde escarbar
del posible trauma infantil escarbar y
en tierra visible en mi comportamiento
adulto y mi personalidad
claramente había un conflicto sexual y
dos trastornos relacionados con el apodo
de mi directora me había dado la
hipomanía y el trastorno
obsesivo-compulsivo de tipo
perfeccionista
para que tengan una referencia algunos
de los síntomas de la hipomanía son
hiperactividad hiper empatía torrente de
ideas y baja necesidad del sueño
por ejemplo anoche solamente dormí dos
horas mientras que el trastorno
obsesivo-compulsivo es un trastorno de
rituales en mi caso canalizados a
sublimar la energía sexual hacia el
artístico lo académico y lo laboral si
bien esta información le proporcionaba
una base
aún no me permite indagar en los vacíos
de mi memoria
a partir de los conocimientos y
herramientas con los que contaba decidió
retomar la intervención en crisis el
relato de hechos era difícil de elaborar
porque sólo tenía un recuerdo borroso
así que decidí documentar todo mi
proceso teniendo siempre a la mano una
pluma y un papel documentar todo palabra
por palabra a través de la escritura
la idea era escribir todos los detalles
incluso que parecían no tener
importancia no sólo de la posible
vivencia traumática sino también del
periodo en que ocurrió
el resultado mi libreta se convirtió en
algo caótico lleno de relatos palabras
fachadas frases escritas en diferentes
direcciones y frases sin sentido hasta
llenarse de información
muchos eran recuerdos de una infancia
plena
para que tengan un antecedente creciendo
un acuario y en mi casa había una fuerte
influencia artística y sentido del humor
escribía sobre cómo usaba los vestidos o
cómo era mi cabello
y después esa sencilla tarea se
convirtió en algo más compulsivo más
descontrolado escribía entonces los
recuerdos que empecé a que empezaron a
llegar como los comportamientos extraños
que tenían la niñez por ejemplo que
despertaba a mitad de la noche llorando
y hecho pipí por las pesadillas mi fobia
a la oscuridad
o mis primeros pensamientos sobre la
muerte
recuerde que cuando la niña jugaba que
violaban a mis muñecas que todos los
días durante la infancia y la
adolescencia me llegue a tocar dos o
tres veces al día hasta lastimarme
recuerdo que cuando era pequeña tenía
terror de que dios me viera a través de
la ventana de que el mes fiar
con el paso de los meses la infancia era
más crear en función de mis emociones
pensamientos conductas reacciones
sensoriales corporales y relaciones con
otras personas si en algún punto suena
como que tenía el control de la
situación no se equivoque
yo no tenía el control de nada
técnicamente estaba siguiendo una línea
pero yo estaba destrozada
había días en que estaba bien y había
días en que me enojo era tan grande que
explotaba contra todos
la angustia comenzó a cobrar forma de
reacciones violentas o impulsivas
llamadas a team outs que están
relacionadas con conflictos reprimidos
de la infancia
al inicio eran horribles y peligrosos
entonces tuve que empezar a escribir
todo lo que sentía pensaba o hacía
durante esos momentos hasta que
solamente fue necesario respirar o
escribir para calmarme de nuevo y
desactivarlos
gradualmente comencé a dar forma a los
textos de ordenarlos por año si
recordaba una muñeca buscaba el modelo y
el año de sus comerciales en mexico si
recordaba un vestido era más fácil
identificar de qué edad a qué edad lo
había usado y preguntaba a mi familia
por diferentes elementos para relacionar
las fechas
pero en este proceso yo debía tener
muchísimo muchísimo cuidado porque
podían empezar a aparecer recuerdos
falsos inducidos o alterados pero en
lugar de ellos comenzaron a llegar más
memorias de los domingos
recuerde que dos primas me llevaban a su
casa y que me encerraban en la
habitación de su mamá a oscuras donde
esperaban otros dos primos
recuerde como me tocaban como temblaba y
como apretaba los ojos por el miedo
recuerde el asco y el ardor que sentía
como llegaba a mi casa a bañarme para
quitarme el olor de la saliva
y como terminaba sintiendo más ardor por
el contacto con el jabón
recuerde que en casa de otra tía un
primo me obligaba a imitar posiciones de
asquerosas revistas pornográficas para
poder verme tocarme y besarme
y recuerden que uno de esos domingos un
tío vio lo que pasaba y decidió guardar
silencio
después de desmenuzar ordenar
cronológicamente y comprobar datos y
procesar la experiencia escondida tras
el muro de la amnesia
por primera vez podía decir que había
sido abusada sexualmente
muchas personas pensarían que un experto
en emergencias debe tener la capacidad
para resolver rápido y con el menor
coste psicológico posible una crisis
personal pero a mí me llevo bastante
tiempo porque decidí abrir la herida
para que si algo debía sangrar lo
hiciera
hasta que no quedara nada
los pasos de la intervención en crisis
habían sido cubiertos ha identificado el
acontecimiento el malestar el grado de
desorganización había realizado una
intervención para disminuir la angustia
había realizado un sondeo de soluciones
y alternativas de afrontamiento
y había preservado mi vida
pero faltaba lo más importante dar un
nuevo significado al evento perturbador
así que con los textos que tenían
comencé a escribir un libro de poemas
cuyas bases para que otros
sobrevivientes se identificarán eran mis
propias alteraciones que correspondían
con las consecuencias psicológicas a
corto y largo plazo del abuso sexual
infantil
en el orden lineal los textos se
abordaban en la infancia de ensueño con
mi familia materna
después aparece la ruptura de la burbuja
rosa y después aparecía mi familia
paterna la corrupción el incesto el
fanatismo religioso y el miedo
algo curioso
es que siempre me interesó traducir los
trastornos al lenguaje y que al final
conseguí hacerlo pero contando mi propia
historia allí estaba todo allí estaba
todo desde el rescate de la voz infantil
hasta la voz mórbida de las mentes
mientras que el trastorno obsesivo
compulsivo se manifestaba a través de
frases y silencios muy exactos muy
elaborados los atinados surgían como
poemas tropezados con un ritmo que no
permitía respirar
la clave del libro está en sus
estructuras ritmos polifonía y en el uso
variable de la puntuación pero más
importante que todo eso en el mapa de
lectura que permite nueve formas de
desglosar ese mundo interno para ver más
allá de lo visible para ver más allá de
lo que un niño consciente de lo que
escribe decide mostrar con tal de no ser
tratado de una manera distinta
cuando mi libro fue publicado ocurrieron
tres cosas importantes la primera y mi
favorita de todas es que el abuso perdió
poder sobre mí porque el hecho de tener
que leer mi historia una y otra y otra
vez en diferentes presentaciones sirvió
como una forma de enfrentamiento y de
sensibilización sistemática como una
forma de procesar lo que había pasado y
deslindar me de una culpa que no me
correspondía para dársela a quienes
realmente debían cargar con ella mis
agresores
la segunda es que recibió una violenta
amenaza de la madre de dos de mis
agresoras quien por cierto sabía de los
abusos
y la tercera es que empezar a recibir
mensajes de personas que habían leído el
libro y se sentían identificadas por
cada palabra que escribían cosas como
sobre toda la tarde con tu libro moviste
muchas cosas en mí
es como si tu voz fuera mi voz
puedo sentir tus lágrimas al escribirlo
no estoy en un fuerte shock
por primera vez entendí el efecto que mi
libro podía tener en otras personas para
motivarlos a hablar a veces por primera
vez en lo que les había pasado
cuando hablo con sobrevivientes y me
dicen totalmente resignados que nunca
podrán superar el abuso yo confirmo que
ya no me siento así ni siquiera un
instante pero puedo decirles que ellos
exactamente en donde están es
exactamente lo que están sintiendo para
que estuve ahí estuve ahí cada segundo y
justamente por eso sé que se enfrenta en
el sufrimiento pueden hacer de su crisis
su mayor fortaleza y crecer no a pesar
de los problemas sino gracias a ellos
obteniendo algo positivo de ellos como
un aprendizaje por ejemplo
actualmente estoy trabajando en una
plataforma para que sobrevivientes
puedan leer el libro y replicar el
proceso y estoy coordinando para estoy
dirigiendo un programa educativo de
empoderamiento infantil orientado a
fortalecer a las diversas infancias a
través de la educación psicológica de
esta manera intervengo no solamente para
que no vivan abusos ahora sino también
para prevenir que en 20 30 o 40 años
ellos se sientan paralizados
porque un recuerdo terrible llegó de la
nada
recuerden que les hablaba de la
importancia de dar un nuevo significado
al evento perturbador para mí haber
vivido abuso sexual infantil a lo largo
de 5 años en un cálculo aproximado de
por lo menos 240 días de abuso significo
algo más grande
que el simple hecho de ser víctima de un
trauma infantil como el descubrimiento
temprano de mi sexualidad a través de la
violencia
para mí se convirtió en la oportunidad
de realizar mi primer viaje a europa por
dos meses y casi todo pagado para
trabajar con sobrevivientes de abuso
sexual infantil en proyectos de arte y
por supuesto en ese periodo también me
la pasé comiendo muchos chocolates
se convirtió también en un colectivo de
empoderamiento de sobrevivientes que ya
tiene sedes en méxico cuba argentina
uruguay perú y brasil
estar en la oscuridad no hizo de mí o la
persona oscura y logra acabar con mi
vocación por el manejo de crisis al
contrario me enseñó que aunque duela hay
que estar en los lugares donde nadie
quiere estar
[Música]